the United States wants to ban Tick-Tock
they say that Tick-Tock is Chinese
spyware designed to intrude on the
privacy and lives of Americans and there
is some truth to this
I mean Tick Tock doesn't even try to
hide it if you go on to their privacy
policy page they clearly list out
exactly what they collect they of course
collect the classic stuff like what
device you're using your IP address and
your location but they also collect some
more sus items like your Biometrics
including your face print and a voice
print and that's just the things that
they admit to who knows what other data
does CC I mean Tick Tock may be
collecting and what exactly they're
doing with this data to be honest though
tick tock's data collection is not all
that different from Facebooks or Googles
or even apples but since they're a
Chinese company countries have been a
lot more cautious in fact several
notable countries have already banned
the app like India who banned it nearly
three years ago at this point the US has
also started taking action earlier this
year dozens of college campuses banned
the use of tick tock on at school Wi-Fi
Tick Tock has also been banned on
government devices and its CEO has been
real killed in Congress but likely the
scariest part for tick tock is the fact
that both sides of government are
uniting on this issue some Democrats
have even gone as far as admitting that
Donald Trump was right about Tick Tock
the entire time that's when you know
you're really screwed but if you thought
that Tick Tock was going to lay down and
take this beating you'd be mistaken
three years ago a band was not something
that they were anticipating meaning that
they had to do it as the U.S said it
including selling themselves to Oracle
but this time they've had plenty of time
to prepare and it looks like they
already have an extensive three-phase
plan in place they're currently working
on the third phase of this plan which is
by far the most evil as they're
essentially buying out a bunch of
Americans so join me as we dive deep
into tick tock's sneaky plan to avoid
getting banned
coming out on top on any deal is quite
easy the key is to have leverage three
years ago America had all the leverage
as it was Tick Tock that was dependent
on America they were dependent on
American creators American viewers and
most importantly American consumerism
and addiction these things are still
very much true which gives the US
government quite a bit of power so the
key for tick tock is to overcome this
dependency and the easiest way to do
that is to ensure that the US is even
more dependent on Tick Tock the first
step in making this the reality was
addressing the American economy by
launching Tick-Tock ads in June of 2020.
to be honest the usage of tick tock ads
is still quite Low by big brands most
brands just don't want to get involved
with short form cringe content but a lot
of drop shippers and e-commerce gurus
have apparently made it work leading to
a decent amount of Revenue in fact Tick
Tock is expected to pull in at 8 0.75
billion dollars worth of Revenue this
year and 11 billion dollars worth of
Revenue next year just from the US but
wait a minute doesn't this just make
tiktok even more dependent on the US
well that's how it appears at first
glance but it's not really true
for one tiktok's parent company by dance
pulled in 80 billion dollars worth of
Revenue last year so the revenue from
Tick Tock us is only about 10 still 10
is not a bad amount right well that is
until you consider that bite dance
actually lost 7 billion by running Tick
Tock so financially speaking by dance
will be just fine without Tick Tock in
fact they'll be better off this isn't to
say that bite dance wants to lose Tick
Tock but they're by no means dependent
on this Revenue do you know who is
dependent on Tick Tock though creators
and advertisers who built their
businesses around the platform so it's
not America who's making Tick-Tock a
viable business it's actually by dance
who subsidize the American creators and
advertisers think about this every
minute people consume 167 million hours
of tick tock assuming that the average
Tick Tock is viewed for 15 seconds we're
talking about 668 million views per
minute
according to tick tock themselves 25 of
these views go to American creators
which translates to 167 million views
per minute that's the same as wait for
it 87 trillion views per year I had to
double check that number like seven
times because it just seemed so wrong
but that's the number 87 trillion now
Tick Tock doesn't pay very much per view
they only pay about 2-4 cents per
thousand views so that 87 trillion views
translates to just 1.75 billion dollars
but we all know that the real money on
Tick Tock isn't with Tick Tock ads it's
with sponsorships and brand deals for
creators Tick Tock ad revenue is likely
at most five percent of their total Tech
talk Revenue meaning that American
creators alone are actually pulling in
closer to 30 to 40 billion through Tick
Tock and if companies are paying
creators this much they're likely
pulling in three to four times that
themselves so we're talking about a 100
billion economy here the vast majority
of which doesn't even go to tick tock
for perspective if Tick-Tock us was a
country it would rank 63 on the GDP list
and all of this is only possible because
bite dance is subsidizing the platform
so who's the one who really needs Tick
Tock to survive bite dance or this
hundred billion dollar industry clearly
it's the latter but tick tock's
influence on the American economy goes
much deeper than just craters and
advertisers
[Music]
Tick Tock has clearly built a thriving
social media economy in the us but as we
previously touched on this primarily
consists of small businesses and
individual creators the apples and the
coca-colas of the world don't really
want to get involved on one hand this is
a good thing bidetans can argue that a
ban on Tick Tock would simply harm small
business owners like this guy I mean do
you really want to screw up this guy's
business of course not but sympathy only
goes so far if you really want Congress
to be on your side you need money now
this easy I mean by dance has plenty of
cash but there's no chance that they
could just directly Lobby Congress if
some Congressman accepts lobbying
dollars from bike dance they're
literally advertising that they don't
want to be re-elected so that's not
gonna work but what if you introduced a
proxy a middleman that could effectively
translate cash to political influence
hmm where could you possibly find that
oh yeah the entirety of the big tech
industry wasn't there that one tech
company that was willing to buy Tick
Tock I think their name was Oracle why
not just partner with them oh wait
that's exactly what they're doing in mid
2022 tiktok agreed to store all of their
us data on oracle's databases and that
all traffic would be routed through
Oracle servers don't mistake this for
tick tock actually giving up control
though they're going to continue storing
backups themselves because they want to
ensure that they don't lose access to
your that I mean they don't want you to
lose access to your data it's not just
Oracle that they're partnering with
either they've purchased 800 million
dollars worth of cloud services from
Google they've partnered with Microsoft
on an AI project and they're integrating
Shopify into Tick Tock these
Partnerships accomplish two goals for
tick tock for one these companies can
vouch for tick tock that they are indeed
properly storing their data and not
using it for nefarious purposes at least
not the data that's stored on Oracle
servers in America and two these
companies can work through Connections
in Congress and persuade them to go easy
on Tick Tock because well Tick Tock is a
big partner customer for them this in
itself is a pretty strong case for Tick
Tock but it gets even better for them
Tick Tock can also argue that they're
supporting big American businesses and
even pushing forward AI development in
conjunction with Microsoft in reality
all they're doing is buying out the
support of these big tech companies but
buying out businesses is just phase two
of tick tock's grand plan the real power
comes from Bangkok people which is
exactly what they're doing now
[Music]
by now I'm sure you're all well aware of
the big Tech layoffs everyone from
Google and Facebook to Microsoft and
Amazon is laying off tens of thousands
of people this is precisely what bite
dance is doing as well they're also
laying off thousands of people but
there's a caveat virtually all of bite
dances layoffs are concentrated in China
in the meantime they're not only
maintaining headcount in America but
they're aggressively expanding headcount
in fact they currently have over 3 400
positions open most of which are in the
US now you might be wondering what type
of person would take such a big risk and
join such a sketchy company well the
answer is virtually everyone given the
right compensation and let's just say
tick tock is hitting compensation out of
the park take this data engineering
position for example there's nothing
especially noteworthy about it it's it's
not a director position or a VP position
or even a manager position the
qualifications aren't that crazy either
they're just looking for one year of
experience in these basic areas by all
accounts this is a basic entry level
position that is until you look at the
compensation up to a quarter million
dollars base when you throw in stock
compensation and bonuses you're easily
looking at three hundred to four hundred
thousand dollars for an entry-level data
engineer position let's take a look at
another one this one is a data scientist
position and looking for just three
years of experience for some context
let's take a look at what Google pays
for an entry-level data scientist they
pay 180 000 that's already a stellar
salary and one of the best offers you
can get but tick tock's minimum base
itself is larger than Google's total
comp again if your turn stock into bonus
you're looking at 300 to 350 for an
entry level position hearing that I'm
sure you're wondering what Tick Tock
pays for Act was in your position well
here's your senior product manager
position Tick Tock is offering a base of
up to four hundred thousand dollars for
perspective even Google's directors fall
90 000 short of that base also Tick Tock
isn't just posting these random ranges
they're actually following through with
offers this guy for example was already
making 345 at Facebook Tick Tock however
came in with an offer of 525 now if
we're being real here there's no way
that Tick Tock actually values this
person's work at over half a million per
year they can literally pay someone in
China a tenth of that salary and get
them to work nine to nine six days a
week but instead Tick Tock is actively
laying people off in China and replacing
them with American counterparts that are
5 to 10 times as expensive why you ask
well it all has to do with Optics that
guy isn't worth anywhere near half a
million per year for tick tock in terms
of work output but that guy is worth
half a million per year for Tech talk in
terms of optic
Tick Tock already has nearly 7 000
employees in the US and at the current
rate this will grow to the tens of
thousands in no time this way when
Congress finally comes around to taking
action on abandoned 6 or 12 months Tick
Tock can confidently tell Congress yo
we're pro-american we're literally
implying tens of thousands of Americans
at salaries that are one and a half to
two times what even Google offers do you
really want to pull the court on this
operation and that right there is Tick
tock's trump card Congress might be able
to overlook a bunch of teens and their
little influencer businesses but what
they can't Overlook is tens of thousands
of real tech jobs going to Americans and
that right there is why Tick Tock will
never be banned clearly Tick-Tock has
played their cards really well and they
aren't going anywhere anytime soon but
the same can't be said about short form
content check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next one